[Música]
cuántos de nosotros tenemos recuerdos
contados por nuestros padres o abuelos
cosas que tal vez por ser habituales no
le dimos la importancia que realmente
tenían
yo por ejemplo guardo historias contadas
por mi papá de su infancia en su italia
natal como aquellos carnavales en
treviso en que se disfrazaban y se
pintaban la cara con corchos quemados
una vez estando en pleno festejo llegó
un amigo agitado gritándose bruce ebro
que severo le preguntaron severus a la
cama les dijo le habían quemado la cama
a mis abuelos con un corcho mal apagado
de más está decir que tuvieron que
escapar de la casa por unos días a la
casa de un pariente hasta que mi abuelo
se le pasó el enojo
o aquella anécdota de cuando falleció
una criatura la costumbre era que los
chicos del pueblo cargara en el féretro
blanco hasta el cementerio
el sacerdote iba adelante con los
monaguillos y ellos detrás hasta que se
cansaron de cargar apoyaron el ataúd en
el suelo y se sentaron encima a
descansar cuando el cura se dio vuelta y
los vio los quería matar
cómo estás quizás ustedes tengan muchas
historias para contar de sus padres y
abuelos
lo cierto es que así pasó su infancia mi
papá entre travesuras y trabajo en el
campo ya que esta era la actividad
familiar
su vida siguió su curso hasta que en
1939 estalló la segunda guerra mundial
1941 tenía 21 años y él decidió ir a la
guerra
reemplazando un hermano que había sido
convocado pero ya estaba casado él era
soltero y no tenía compromisos
combatió arriesgó su vida día a día en
el campo de batalla enfrentando
situaciones extremas que humanamente no
podríamos comprender pero
lamentablemente necesarias para
sobrevivir
así pasó dos años hasta que en 1943
mussolini es derrocado y el mariscal
badoglio sucesor firma una ministerio
con los con los aliados declarándole la
guerra alemán ya aquí cambió
completamente el destino de mi papá
cuando se rompe el eje el prisionero de
los alemanes y comienzan sus penurias
es tomado en la ex yugoslavia lo llevan
a pie a través del territorio con días
de intensa lluvia sin comida ni abrigos
una caminata de aproximadamente 800
kilómetros sin embargo se mantuvo en pie
y sobrevivió
así llegó a hungría
en hungría junto con otros cientos de
prisioneros lo subieron a un tren y lo
llevaron a austria
en austria lo trasladaron a un campo de
concentración en links donde le quitaron
todas sus pertenencias materiales
curiosamente lo único que pudo conservar
fue este tenedor
que lo acompañó toda su vida y que yo
hoy tengo en mis manos y trato de
invocar esa fuerza a la que él se habrá
cerrado a este objeto insignificante
pero que en su condición era lo único
que le quedaba para mantenerse unido a
su familia
en el campo de concentración lo
obligaron a trabajar en condiciones
infrahumanas
primero en una fábrica de locomotoras en
donde entre otras cosas que sufrió fue
la fractura de una pierna
pero esto no lo detuvo se la acomodaron
como pudieron entre sus compañeros y
siguió adelante luego lo llevaron a un
ingenio de azúcar de remolacha y más
adelante trabajó en el campo cuidando
animales y plantando pinos
en todos estos lugares trabajaba 12
horas por día por un mendrugo de pan y
una ínfima ración de agua que apenas le
alcanzaba para beber y asearse
dormían en barracas sobre piso de madera
con mantas pequeñas que no alcanzaban
abrigarlos lograban darse calor
poniéndose unos contra otros
eran levantados todos los días a las 5
de la mañana los hacían formar filas y
los guardias pasaban revista con perros
si alguno se movía los perros no los
mordían pero eran retirados de la
formación y les propinaban feroces
golpizas
a pesar de todo él siempre busco el lado
positivo a las cosas nos contaba por
ejemplo que en la fábrica de azúcar
tenían la suerte de tomar todo endulzado
y cuando le tocó trabajar en el campo no
le había pasado tan mal
evidentemente le habían quitado todas
sus pertenencias materiales pero lo que
no pudieron quitarle fueron sus
pertenencias internas esa fuerza de
voluntad que lo empujaba a mantenerse
vivo para en algún momento regresar a su
pueblo y reencontrarse con su familia
el para sobrevivir se adapta a las
circunstancias hizo todos los trabajos
que le imponían nunca dijo que no a nada
porque sabía que si no venía la paliza y
hasta podía desaparecer
su voluntad lo mantuvo vivo mejor dicho
le salvó la vida
hasta que una mañana los guardias nazis
no los despertaron
ya no había alemanes custodiando el
campo nadie se los dijo pero la guerra
había terminado y él había recuperado su
libertad
este fue el comienzo del regreso a casa
nunca supe cuántos kilómetros camino esa
vez y creo que él tampoco lo supo hasta
que fueron encontrados por el ejército
estadounidense que los declaro libres lo
subieron a un camión y así fue que
regreso a su querida italia
cuando llegó a su pueblo era una noche
calurosa de 1945 unos chicos jugaban en
la puerta de su casa y cuando lo vieron
corrieron a avisarle a los padres los
que no le creyeron porque habitualmente
les hacían ese tipo de bromas cuando
entró a la habitación y lo vieron no lo
podían creer estaba muy flaco y
desmejorado pero vivo ellos ya lo daban
por muerto sin embargo él volvió gracias
a su fuerza de voluntad
el periodo posterior a la liberación
tampoco fue fácil recordaba los malos
momentos pasados
muchos no pudieron adaptarse no sabiendo
qué hacer con la libertad recuperada
volcándose a la bebida y no pudiendo
rehacer sus vidas
con él se había traído las carteras de
cuatro de sus compañeros caídos en
combate
y se ocupó de hacer la llegada a sus
familias a través del párroco del pueblo
los horrores de la guerra lo seguían
acechando hasta en estos detalles
a pesar de todo
con esa fuerza de voluntad que siempre
tuvo ante las adversidades decidió dar
vuelta a la página y salir adelante y
así fue que sin olvidar lo pasado pero
haciéndolo a un costado en 1948 se vino
para la argentina
con una valija cargada de historias y
con el único capital que le quedaba que
era su fuerza de voluntad su fe en salir
adelante y si también su tenedor
acá trabajo conoció a mi mamá y formó
una familia
para mí todo esto no era más que la
historia de vida de mi papá
él nunca se compadeció de sí mismo y por
lo tanto tampoco insistió en contar lo
que le había pasado
para mí todo esto estaba ahí yo nunca le
pregunté tal vez por respeto o tal vez
porque él tampoco le daba mayor
trascendencia
hasta que mi terapeuta la doctora laura
ares acá me contó la historia de victor
franklin un psiquiatra austríaco y me
recomendó que leyera su libro el hombre
en busca de sentido
quizás alguno de ustedes ya lo conozca y
lo hayan leído yo si bien no lo conocía
leyendo lo comprendí que la historia de
frank él me resultaba muy familiar por
los relatos de mi propio papá
a medida que avanzaba en la lectura de
esos relatos me estremecía en cada vez
más
de este libro rescato una frase en
particular
el hombre es el ser que siempre decide
lo que es
y mi papá fue un luchador incansable
nunca bajó los brazos
aunque le habían arrebatado todo lo
material y lo habían obligado a vivir en
condiciones infrahumanas
lo que no pudieron arrebatarle fue su
libertad interior
su decisión de ser quien él había
decidido ser y decidió ser íntegro
valiente trabajador optimista y hasta
con cierto sentido del humor
creo que todo esto fue el mayor mérito
de su experiencia
y así vivió toda su vida cuando él
comenzaba a hacer algo ya sea pintar una
habitación cortar leña podar los árboles
o hacer su huerta no paraba hasta
terminar no tenía hambre ni sed ni sueño
su único objetivo era terminar
tan admirable fue su personalidad que
hasta en el último momento de su vida
tuvo el coraje de decidir
se sacó la mascarilla de oxígeno y me
dijo basta hasta acá llegué
estoy seguro que muchos de ustedes
tendrán padres y abuelos con mi historia
seguramente muy sorprendentes y quizá
nunca tengan que atravesar este tipo de
experiencias extremas pero les propongo
indagar
conversar conocer esas historias y
descubrir cuánto podemos aprender de
ellas sobre todo en los momentos en que
nos sentimos agobiados por los problemas
miremos hacia atrás revisemos la
historia de nuestros antepasados porque
si nosotros hoy estamos acá seguramente
es porque ellos han tenido que superar
innumerables inconvenientes encontremos
en ellos la inspiración y la fuerza para
superar nuestras propias dificultades
hoy me siento agradecido por tener esta
oportunidad ya que a través de ella la
historia de mi papá llegó hasta ustedes
y espero que la recuerden como el
triunfo de la voluntad
el triunfo de la voluntad frase que los
nazis intentaron apropiarse pero no
pudieron gracias a que hubo gente como
mi papá que además de una gran cuota de
suerte también tuvieron el deseo
inquebrantable de recuperar la libertad
y salir adelante
sinceramente deseo que este pequeño
tributo que intente hacerle a mi viejo
les haya servido para demostrar que se
puede sobrevivir a fuerza de voluntad
[Aplausos]